o pessoal
boa tarde a todos essa fofura que vocês
vêm aí tá aqui no palco com caetano era
meu filho da cissa
essa nossa família e essa família do
paulinho serginho que vem aí essa turma
torna faz parte da família do chão ea
cristiane tanto tinham como paulinho e
outra família que a serra planta na
minha comida ea comida que eu faço por
outras pessoas
e aí quem planta sua comida
meu nome é raro na raquete é um chef de
cozinha e meu sotaque como já temos a
cada um em uma bagunça me bastante
importante em vários países onde eu tive
que esse ano e tomara que vocês
compreendam que eu tô falando hoje
também trouxe até aqui hoje eu quero
relembrar com vocês
o caminho da roça sim o meu caminho da
roça como está aproximadamente assim
esse bichinho que você vem aí sou eu
vai ficar só na província algumas áreas
no interior da província assim como a
capital
'ela é uma zona rural então eu fui
criado na horta na hora da minha avó
a even tomates e abóboras com três
cenários um bichinho do mato mesmo então
laneve mais caro na época dos 80 no
final dos 80 alegre virou praga e e
minha família na família de caçadores
então eu peguei essa costumem como uma
coisa muito interna muito natural desde
o começo minha família passava para
comprar ea a a pele ea carne e exportar
para outros países mas também para nos
alimentar
pra mim essa é a forma mais primitiva de
comércio também quando fiz a parte os
estúdios gastronômicos como esse período
o diploma esse mundo fora cozinhando
pesquisando novas culturas conhecendo
novos e nos produtos
aprender uma nova língua mas também
sempre me interessei por aquele que é
fácil acontecer na terra que o
matrimônio ao patrimônio imaterial
cultura como por exemplo aí no peru com
um trabalho com vários produtores no
parque internacional da batata mas não
somente eu queria mesmo ficar com isso
quando eu cheguei aqui na serra
eu passei seis meses morando no sítio
produção orgânica onde oferecerá
workshops alimentação consciente pra
atacar pessoas possam ter um contato
direto com a roça possam entender a
cadeirinha da alimentação de uma forma
mais holística não somente chegaram no
supermercado pegar a bola e pronto não
se esqueça se não entender de onde há
muita bem quanto trabalho isso demora
por quem é produzido até chegar na mesa
e além
então pra mim é um caminho muito
importante aqui na serra eu fiz um
mapeamento agora os produtores da região
e por isso que me apaixonei por que eu
acho que aqui na serra você tem um
contato direto da roça fica perto de uma
coisa distante como nas grandes cidades
eu como como chefe de cozinha acredita
muito muito nesse caminho
quando as pessoas vão comer o meu
patrolar para uma experiência
gastronômica
conheça dinheiro eu faço na
redistribuição da grana e possa comprar
diretamente pra paulinho pra te amo pra
quem não produtores além de comprar
muita falta pra caetano e olha que ele
precisa para os animais mas melhorei um
pouco isso pegar essa grana fazer uma
redistribuição de renda é ativar e
desenvolver a economia local
geralmente não preocupar por quem está
detrás o produto não somente chegar na
gordura
isso traz muitos benefícios para nossos
equilibrada como um bom desenvolvimento
mas por que a gente esqueça esse caminho
da roça basicamente eu acredito porque a
bíblia sociedades
a cidade começa a aprender um pouco
dessa zona rural é número um
desenvolvimento que haja que o rural é
um sinônimo de atração de precários e
não tem coisa mais rara que é isso
então quando a gente vai ao supermercado
se encontra um monte de coisas prontas
nas prateleiras
você vai ao supermercado e começa a
questão da produção da comida dengue
e aí quando a gente começa a se
perguntar que outra coisa que ela está
fazendo
gente assim que você começa a perceber
por exemplo que essa família que eu
comentei com o começo
comecei a ficar invisível se esquecem é
também acontecem que não seja um
movimento econômico local é porque é
essa grana que você compra o dinheiro
para grandes corporações e também
acontece que você começa já tudo pronto
você vai pegar como já cortada latas
cada
esse tá tudo pronto a gente começa a
perder esse contato direto com o
alimento que uma coleção muito primitiva
de nos levar o primeiro que a gente faz
uma coisa que estou vivendo com meu
filho é se ele vai começar na boca é uma
coisa instintiva
conheça a industrialização da nossa
rotina alimentar também acontece em
outras coisas como por exemplo começamos
a comer marcas sim começamos a
iniciativa muito açúcar gorduras e sais
a cozinha muitas vezes fica esquecida
fica de um metro por um metro até muitas
vezes mas para mas melhor que o banheiro
e aí você começa a entender que
começasse hoje novas enfermidades e
começamos a marca muito rápido
outra coisa que acontece e é muito comum
começamos a pegar qualquer coisa pronta
e comer assistindo tv ou pior ainda
começamos a comer qualquer coisa pronta
assistindo a competição de comida na tv
um absurdo
não dá pra entender é mais acontece
também que a revistas nos ensina muito
sério a perguntar têm glúten sem lactose
em haiti é light será integral orgânico
será que convencional mas não é bom para
as empresas começar se a gente começa a
se perguntar de onde nós a comida tem aí
que a gente vai fazer uma grande
diferença
é uma responsabilidade muito particular
a nossa de poder encontrar essa e no dia
a dia
grandes empresas estão começando a tomar
muita lição pela gente
quando esquecemos esse hábito de
cozinhar
é aí que ele começa a mente a mentira o
endereço da própria comida começa no
parque industrial por exemplo
só tem tempero da horta mas só isso
gente
você acredita que salsinha e se a obtê
lá essa mágica foi tirado da terra que
maravilha nem como falando colega acha
que não mas eu vou colocar vocês pra
você quando chegaram na prateleira
procure saber tá
e tem mais ainda olha só para quem
conhece um pouquinho da roçam alguma vez
botou o pé na terra vai entender que
essa é sua horta e parece ter sido
cultivado por uma empresa videogame é ok
eu acredito que seja mais fácil achar um
pokémon que comprar não é fácil aí não
tem como
e outra coisa também olha não é só
cozinheiras ficam muitas vezes entram
quatro aparelhos e não somente a roça
fica precisa conhecer o processo andou
coragem de trocar a cozinha alimentação
hoje em dia o conseguindo fica muito que
se entrou com outro aparelho somente
pela revista anos o alimento também tem
pressões é fogo faca coisa muito certa
mas eu acredito que essa forma a gente
vai entender um pouco conscientemente o
caminho de onde as coisas bem no cutucar
dia a dia vamos a encontrar este caminho
da roça várias formas por exemplo pra
você ter uma idéia uma panorama local
aqui em petrópolis aproximadamente 1 600
famílias trabalham na agricultura
familiar se sobretudo e localizar na
parte do velho região caxambu na região
de itaipava
colocar a gente começa a se perguntar de
onde a comida bem é é aí que a gente
começa a se interessar do jeito que eu
tenho um bom tempo atrás você começa a
comer bem melhor
e olha que comer bem melhor significa
preparar vai permitir ser envenenado
porque meus amigos aqui no brasil
monte de agrotóxicos que são permitidas
estão banindo lá fora já são proibidas e
tem mais tem essa lei é a hora querendo
falar que por exemplo o queiros
agrotóxico pode ter um nome fantasia da
marelli defensivo fitossanitários vira
chique né
com esse nome
é um absurdo mas eu tenho pra você onde
poderão encontrar essas famílias a
família que produzem organicamente
aquino na região também temos
aproximadamente 100 família que são
certificados pela e cpg que um sistema
participativo de garantia baixo olhar do
davi uip matando rio
essa família se os produtores locais da
agricultura familiar orgânica a
cronologia banda roça capina mão sim
utilizam técnicas agrofloresta para
criar nos alunos o sistema utiliza
naquele matos entre aspas a nosso favor
então acreditem que a agricultura
orgânica é muita má relação que ela terá
convencional mas vale a pena
vale a pena por vários antiga
principalmente porque não mata o
produtor e muito menos a quem consome
parece muito benefício promessas e
equilibraram então onde podemos
encontrar essas famílias
as férias consegui sendo o caminho mais
direto para a roça dentro do que uma
cidade pode diretamente ofegante
perguntar onde venho
tem também a junta local que faz muito
bem esse trabalho pode também se
cadastrar em 60 as orgânicas diretamente
com o produtor
vocês têm uma festa dedicada ao caso
mensalmente na conta coletiva como por
exemplo a rede ecológica aqui na serra
que tem um núcleo podem adquirir um
monte de produtos orgânicos e e de boa
procedência e aquele que mais
tradicionais aquele mercadinho do bairro
e hortomercado que é onde o produtores e
se juntam para poder dar vazão a toda
essa produção que faz uma semana
eu acredito que nossa responsabilidade
seja procurar novas formas de consumo
que vem num verdadeiro valor do campo a
roça
sim quero resgatar essa costumem que
resgatem comemorem essa costuma
compartilhar boa mesa porque definiu a
gastronomia um pouco isso sim ter muito
chique muito complicado a gastronomia
são saberes que estão ligados em torno
ao comércio é meu saber é o sábado vocês
vão saber da boca imagina que não
consegue cozinhar muito melhor que é o
16 mas muitas vezes isso fica com sua
chefe estrela fica perdido
é aí onde os saberes a parte cultural e
política da comida fica para lá e como
você terá ouvido falar
começa a se alimentar é um ato político
porque porque a gente pode escolher onde
direcionava os ingressos ea grana da
nossa comida
se a gente tomar essa decisão de uma
forma mais consciente vai chegar
diretamente no bolso do pequeno produtor
para ele voltar o filho na aula de
inglês para comprar aquele brinquedo no
mercadinho da chiquinha para comprar
novas mudas para votar na terra e fazer
circular nessa cadeia tola
nós mantemos aqui não está matando
esse é o lema é eu trouxe aqui hoje 3
passa por uma revolução alimentar faz se
sempre na receita não muito complicada
qualquer um que fala que ele é no
cursinho hoje passar primeiro é como um
produto que seja utilizado e começar a
fazer vocês pra vocês pra sua família ao
supermercado
segundo vamos comprar medicamentos da
pessoa da senhora do cara do daquele que
está na na banquinha da todo o mercado
procure saber compreender que as pessoas
e 3º vamos aplicar em seus espaços para
o maximo produto é possível
olha aí vocês vão começar a comer muito
melhor vai encontrar um link de
possibilidade para sua alimentação e vai
deixar a contribuir no sistema e que
está demorando a uma sociedade se possa
trazer a primeira sugestão para essa
revolução
vamos falar um pouco na receita bem
básica
vamos começar a fazer um molho de tomate
terceiro na tabela acontecer benefícios
que isso traz para a sociedade e para a
sua saúde
1º é comemorado o mate para o motivo é
uma coisa muito mais gostosa ser feito
em casa que se abrir uma latinha não tem
dúvida é prática o bota na massa volta
em uma pista fácil na sopa podem fazer
grande quantidade congelar em pouquinho
e já pronto
facilita a vida mas sempre que tem feito
em casa
segundo aqui no brasil uma empresa só é
dona de cinco marcas a tomar tal como
ele já então se a gente deixa de
contribuir nessa hora
o trio deixa de comprar esse molho
pronto a gente vai perceber que vai
votar só 45 têm reais e nem para o vôo
só de ida grande indústria de tomate
pronto que já são já é de 160 milhões
aqui no brasil
indiretamente o cara da roça vai fazer
uma grande diferença na saúde
principalmente como estava falando não
perceber que vai deixar de consumir um
monte de de químicos para sua dieta por
exemplo
assim durante assim o city começou a ter
sol e blá blá blá blá blá é muito
difícil processo imagina com sotaque é
hora ainda têm muito açúcar tem muitas
ao muito veneno
não adianta então minha proposta um
pouco isso pra vocês sabem também o
tomate eo não é segredo entrou na
cozinha e que recebe mais agrotóxico
antes de chegar à nossa mensagem
aproximadamente 25 doses sim então você
recolhemos esse produto e trouxe a esta
sugestão hoje e não ia sair do palco
conseguindo deixar receita pra vocês
então rapidinho a forma bem didática
quando ontem da feira contou só pensa
esse molho de tomate em de construção da
rosa porque aí tá na forma mais pura
pega na bola bater nela bota na cet
também trafegava na cenoura volta um
pouquinho no cunhão e tomate cortado em
cubinhos tempero sal pimenta um golinho
de vinho que sobre a noitada anterior
que sempre quer em casa um pouquinho de
calma deixa de produzir e aí no final
atacou um monte de magical fresco tá bom
então gente muito bom apetite
obrigado pelo apetite de vocês e vamos a
caminho de volta para a roça